so the internet not social networks has
by the way why am I stuck in air quotes
always hardcore fans don't talk about so
the Internet is a is stuck in a place
where people have realized that it's
disrupted publishing you read books on
Kindles an iPad I can go direct with my
future books may not uh music right we
download music now no more CDs commerce
you buy things on Amazon you know all
these things have happened but the one
thing that we don't talk about is the
Internet is really disrupting media
companies quite a bit the cost of entry
to become a media company is so low you
don't have to buy a TV network anymore
you don't need to buy a multi-million
dollar printing press to reach the end
consumer you literally use products that
are free like WordPress and medium and
now because of the word of mouth which
is the plumbing of society now that
social networks have mapped that social
networks if you don't know if you've got
two twisted social networks are the
plumbing of word-of-mouth in our society
now so with that which is distribution
which is really what media is and with
free sites like WordPress and medium
things of that nature which is the
content production aspect basically the
cost to get out there is double zero
Robert Parish now here's what's really
happening where I think people are
misunderstanding things is that the cost
of entry to being relevant in our
society today is content if you're not
putting out stories you basically don't
exist and so what I really want to make
this video about is for once it for all
to put a stake in the ground or my fist
at his table and I'm Khrushchev style
since on Russia every one of you is a
media company now I know people hate
hearing the term personal brand it feels
icky fine call it your reputation and I
know it might sound like everybody's a
media company so cliche marketing talk
fine call it what you want but if you
are not putting out content that is
bringing value to people whether it's
making you giggle whether that's making
you think whether that's educating you
on wine or business or whatever it may
be if you're not putting out that
content
you were betting being drowned out by
the massive volume of content that is
being put out by businesses media
companies entrepreneurs on and on and on
and if you don't understand this and you
head into a 2014 world and you don't
have a very strategic strategy on
putting out content on a daily basis a
weekly basis that's actually bringing
value to the end consumer which then
reciprocates you getting business you
will be left out in the cold
you will be blockbuster you will be the
person at that press or video you will
be the person that owned a ton of horses
before the car you will be borders books
that laughed at Amazon you can laugh at
all this video all you want but I'm
looking forward to having a conversation
with you in four years if you do not act
on this rant